what's up everyone welcome back for
another comic con 2022 interview i have
the cast and the director behind a
kick-ass movie with us right now bodies
bodies bodies your movie is so good it's
so my kind of thing congratulations
you're all electric in it you direct the
crap out of it oh thank you so seriously
oozing with style and i absolutely loved
it question for all of you is this
everybody's first horror movie it's
certainly mine yes me too oh wow
um i need to go down the line very
briefly what is your absolute favorite
horror movie or the very first horror
movie you saw that terrified you very
first was the exorcist very favorite
mid-summer excellent choices right there
um the one that traumatized me the most
was um like a michael myers moment
um and my favorite one to date is body's
body spawning that makes all the sense
in the world i get it
i think uh one of my favorite horror
movies is green room
it's really
did you do you like it i am obsessed
or did you not like it it was it was one
of my top 10 of whatever year it came
out i want to say 2014. and i usually
don't like gore because it's kind of
gross but i thought that the story was
so good that it was
really good i think one of the first
ones that i remembered and liked was it
follows
i have posters of both so i approve of
both of those answers right now
i love rosemary's baby just because i'm
obsessed with john cassavetes he's the
greatest of all time to me and then the
fifth element which is not even
considered horror but the blue lady in
the fifth element look her up she's
frightening was the stuff of my
nightmare for a decade straight
uh the first movie that terrified the
hell out of me was probably the shining
i don't know why my dad my dad would
like force me to watch his favorite
movies with him when i was little
including the shining which i'm like sus
but also like fantastic film taste dad
thanks um and then
my favorite movie now my favorite horror
movie now is probably hereditary ooh
a lot of a24 love here i'm all for that
i'm all for that all right so given the
game you play in the movie it does make
me wonder whether it's bodies bodies
bodies or any variation on the game did
you all ever play and if you did who was
the best at it
yes we played yes and we've agreed that
maria was the best really fantastic
i don't know what to say
i'm not sure is this a compliment is it
actually a critic
okay well the reason we should say that
she is the best is because we did all
play when we first met and
you know we were going around being like
you're the one you're the one no i'm not
the one defending ourselves and maria
was dead silent the entire time and
finally like we some of us got so worked
up nearly to tears that we were like
maybe we should and then i was like hold
on
maria hasn't said a word and then there
she look at that face
playing
i just
i just played a game long time ago
dare i ask who was the worst
me it was me it was me because everyone
kept thinking that i was the murderer
and i wasn't and i literally the the
i guess i look like a killer but
everyone kept being like it's you and i
was like it's really not
yeah so rachel
rachel cannot tell a lie she has too
much anxiety but playing this game with
playing this game with actors is really
like you don't understand what to
believe because that could have been the
performance of a lifetime is rachel
getting really worked up so it's like
it's very you plays tricks on them
definitely yeah it messes with you i get
it i can't lie i have no poker face
whenever i play among us with my friends
like i'm literally always the loser
there is no hope for me in those games
whatsoever
a question for the whole cast except for
you maria because i've asked this to you
and i liked your answer for the four of
you the cast chemistry is of the utmost
importance in this and i know you all
have different styles and different
backgrounds when it comes to your acting
is there anything you saw somebody else
do on the set of this film a technique
they used that you put in your back
pocket and said i want to try that
either on this film or in a future film
what a great question yeah yeah that's
good wait i have i have one that chase
gave to me
and it was i forget the name of it but
it's like
yes you say to yourself
going into the scene like hey
like
um this isn't real like we're gonna go
into this world whatever
and like and then you go into it and
then when you leave you're like we're
leaving you said it's so much better but
i did it and it was great and it was
really helpful and it felt like in my
head i would see myself going into an
elevator into hell
and at the beginning of every day and i
was like there we go and then i would
leave at the end of the day and it was
very helpful just like a verbal like
recognition that you're kind of
morphing your brain into something else
i stole that from chase too i still do
that now because of chase
yeah and i i felt completely insane at
first like driving to work by myself
like talking to myself out loud like hey
girl
today's gonna be fun it's not real but
it actually does it does do something
i'm glad that makes me happy i too
took this technique from chase i'm
getting the vibes that maybe we've all
been deeply traumatized by all the work
that we've done but yeah there was um
same conversation about uh allowing like
reminding yourself that whatever you've
just done did not it's not
real and you're gonna go into your life
and chase was like oh i made this
specific playlist that i listened to
after that helps me
pull myself out and i really connect to
music so that was that was a good one
that i've held on to as well come on
chase
wait but now chase i want your answer
what what technique did you take from
one of your co-stars exactly okay here
we go here we go chase is like nothing
not one thing i learned everything from
myself self-taught
i i mean i feel like every i think the
improv was a whole nother ball game on
this set i mean like rachel's like
comedy background and and just like her
b i think everyone being able to like
drop in and the fact that helena like
staged it like a play and just being
able to like look at anyone and it's
it's kind of like a fear dance that i
feel like everyone on the set was able
to play so well of like
you're either dropped in or you're like
sinking so so just that kind of improv
skill i think is something i've learned
from every everybody on this set we are
going to get into that improv cause i'm
so curious how that panned out for your
editor but it worked out really great
for the movie in the end but first
before we get there i want to know a
little bit about the evolution of the
story because correct me if i have any
of my details wrong helena but you
adapted this or kristen adapted this
from her own story her own short story
she wrote the screenplay then you
brought in sarah to work on it a little
bit and then you obviously directed it
so can you tell me a little bit about
the defining quality that everybody
added to the project every step of the
way i think she wrote it originally
christian just as a script because she
was
with her friends one weekend and she
wrote it like as a as a script and then
me and sarah sort of rewrote it or
mainly sarah of course but with my input
into what it is
what it was when they got it and then
all of their inputs you know changed
that and then on top of that there was
improvisation so there were so many
layers to it and i think i mean i really
keep saying this like i'm 46 i want to
make a movie about gen z i better open
myself up completely to these young
people and collaborate with them and
also i come from the theater i'm an
actress myself so i really wanted to
create a small theater ensemble even
though they had not met before so this
was quite a challenge but we all got
into it and it really worked out great
what is the difference betw what is the
biggest difference between draft one of
the screenplay and what we see in the
final film
if i answer that
i spoil yes because the big there's a
huge like plot thing that that is made
that i think also defined
what it has become but i think mainly
for me myself i come from radical art
house and to take this project on and to
make it really entertaining was my
challenge but also to make it dark and
meaningful you know so i feel that sarah
the lab who comes from the theater also
added a lot to that but they did too
because i think it's so much fun this
film but at the same time of course it
has a little hidden message yeah yeah i
do i love that in my horror as much as i
love the thrills like the fleeting
thrill of just watching something and
then having a good time i like how much
horror nowadays is getting into real
world challenges because for some reason
i have an easier time processing things
through horror movies than in real life
so oh i get that i get that yeah yeah i
totally get it part of the reason why i
love the genre so much all right so
let's get into this improvisation so i
read that helena likes to prepare
prepare prepare so that you guys can
just go for it on set so when you hit
set and you go for it can you each give
me an example of something that started
in one place but then completely morphed
on set that really surprised you
i think the one scene that really took a
turn i was not expecting was a scene in
the basement
with in the gym in the sorry in the gym
it was the basement of the house we were
filming it but the basketball court
slash gym area where we can i talk about
plot points i don't know how this works
very lightly maybe yeah maybe let's not
spoil anything
yeah
something frightening you know on the
page it says like
the girls are in there they meet so and
so this happens they leave and we were
in there for like
hours upon hours and it evolved to
something so much more
horrific than i expected it to be and i
think that actually translates a lot on
my face in the film because
like if if a normal person would react
to that and be like oh my gosh but i'm
stood there like this
the whole time because i i just didn't
expect it to become as
as um like
deep and real as it was i thought it was
going to be kind of like quick and dirty
and and then we spent a whole day like
creating this i mean rachel should talk
about this
well i was just gonna say a moment that
i felt like like was there's a scene
towards the end where we all um kind of
air our grievances
and that was like and the script is
again the script is so good and
everyone's character is so defined so
it's
easy to improv because you know
like who you are and what you would say
and i feel like things
came out in the fight
that
were so fun to say and like
yeah
it was really and we brought a little
bit of ourselves into it too there were
certain things like i was talking about
this earlier today where i was saying
something like a dinner to the cast and
then helena was like say that in the
movie and like because it's just like
you bring little pieces of yourself and
i think that's so fun
and really juicy there's also that part
the party scene that we filmed where
it's i think like leading up to it
helena would be like i'm so excited for
our party on friday night it's like like
we were having a party but it was like a
full day of 12 hours of work but like
the work was us all being unhinged in
this party setting with like again like
not like having you know pieces on on
the page but really just like out of in
a party setting like everyone has their
own agenda and so we were all just like
running around like going crazy with
like this unchained camera that could
catch us at any moment
that is absolutely wild that you shot
the film that way i'm going back to my
editor question now how how much footage
did you actually go into the edit with
compared to whatever the average is and
is there anything that was especially
hard to cut out of the final film well
the funny thing about this whole thing
is that i'm not an educated filmmaker so
i uh i'm very intuitive and i this is
how i like to work and rdp josper who
also comes from the netherlands loves
that way of working too and so on my
first film we did that too so of course
the editor's like wait what is going on
because there's a lot of handheld
there's enormously long takes but i feel
i want to bring the same atmosphere as i
had in my theater group with eva von
hofer to them and and like make it for
them so that that things can happen that
are unpredictable that they totally get
into it so i'm very relieved to hear
that they all tell themselves it's not
real it's not real but that i mean i
mean it's a funny but at the same time
it's true because we create an
atmosphere in which things almost feel
documentary but i think
both editors who worked on this film
absolutely loved it and one of them was
the editor of green room so i think like
they really got into it but at first it
might be a little bit like overwhelmed
by what kind of material they received
doesn't surprise me to hear that i love
when all my favorite people work
together um just to highlight all of
your characters individually right now
can you each go down the line and say
one thing you really admire about your
character a quality that you would
actually want to take with you but then
what is one of her biggest weaknesses or
flaws that the audiences should keep an
eye out for as the story unfolds
okay uh
something that i admire about my
character
is
if she's feeling something if she wants
something if she wants to say something
she does it she goes for it
um
with not a ton of thought necessarily um
but i think that makes her very
passionate
and open and honest and it also can be a
double-edged sword it can also be very
dangerous i feel like everyone's best
quality is a double-edged sword and
could
yeah yeah i was going to say somewhere
like also a double edged sword sort of
qualities like
emma amidst great adversity her
boyfriend could be screaming in her face
spitting in her eyes and she could just
be like
hold her composure as best she can
there's like a resilience that is
admirable about that um but at the same
time
resilience can lead to deep repression
of
dark dark demons and i think back in
ruins had in uglier ways but yeah
i think the only i think not the only
thing i kind of like
i think i think i appreciate the fact
that she's much braver than me because i
couldn't be that brave uh but i don't
really enjoy the fact that um
she is not trust
worthy and she is not trusting people as
well uh i'm not trusting people easily
as well so that's why it's kind of
the only mutual thing between me and my
character but yeah maybe these two i
don't
um i feel like alice loves to have fun
she just wants everyone to have a good
time she wants
things to go well
um she wants to dance you know
and i love that i think her
weakness
is she is so um
quick
to um
jump at some i can't i can't think of
the best word to describe it but she'll
change her mind really quick
like i feel like a lot in the movie i'm
like
it's this person's the killer no this
person's the killer and this it's him
and it's a boo-boo and i think like she
doesn't really ever slow down and maybe
that's like the other side of the party
fun aspect is she's kind of like
frantic i don't know what that hitting
the table thing was but yeah tell us
about your character helena
um
one of the things i admire the most
about jordan is her leadership we'll
call it leadership when things start to
go awry she sort of grabs all the
sharpest things and says
i'm going to protect and we're going to
find out and you know you know i think
that's like you know go get our attitude
that's great love that um
the thing
about jordan that i think is her
weakness is that
she's like i'm the biggest smartest
strongest but she's also like one of the
least truthful people and she like saves
all of her ammunition
until she can like leverage it against
someone and i find that very sneaky and
sad
oh my god the pairing of these qualities
all right so
you guys have played a version of body's
bodies bodies but i have a different
game for you right now
i played this on my ladies night series
every once in a while and it just feels
too appropriate to do this so i love
horror movies clearly i want to throw
like all of you the real you into a
slasher scenario so i am going to give
you some descriptions and whoever jumps
in first is going to give me the right
answer so tell me who best applies to
this description
first one is of the group who is most
likely to not realize that they're in a
horror movie and go and investigate a
strange noise and then just immediately
get killed by the killer chase
oh this is right
this is really light i'm not sure why
i'm sorry
no i honestly think it's i think it's
rachel okay sorry i think it's rachel
too because i dropped a perfect angel
she's a perfect angel and i dropped
rachel i dropped rachel off at her house
the other day and she was like why is
the door turned like a normal door
handle or so it was like something
really small and then you go and then
you just yes oh yeah no that was
actually scary there were two no sorry
there were two cards around your block
it was scary but it wasn't that scary
and then we used to we stayed on the
phone for 10 minutes yeah until you
figured it out but i went in yeah yeah
but you went in
okay maybe it is you why did you okay
the reason i said you is because one day
we were on set and we were playing like
a truth or dare and chase walked away
and i dared amandla to be really like
standoffish and rude to chase
well so i was like just just like don't
even look at her and then when she says
something kind of go like
and and see just like how long how long
until she twisted something's going on i
know this is coming to life like i can't
wait yeah bring on the sympathy please
thank you
so then we were doing it and chase for
like i i thought she was going to last
that long because chase doesn't take
[ __ ] you know what i mean and then like
five minutes in she like amanda would be
like that's kind of a weird thing you
just said and chase was like
um like what's go and then we all bust
up laughing and poor rachel was like
almost in tears because she thought it
was so mean and wrong it was kind of
crazy
it was very like within the culture of
the people we were playing you know that
i could help you drop in guys
all right next question
i gotta let you guys go soon i'll
squeeze in two more let's highlight a
like a really good positive quality in
someone
who is the most likely to sacrifice
themselves for the group oh my gosh
rachel yeah helena yeah yeah selena
helena yeah that is the right answer to
that question you're a fearless leader
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i will protect
you yeah yeah yeah
all right this is my favorite one i'll
end on this
who is the most likely
to
come back at the last possible second
like you think they're dead but then
they save the day when you think that
all hope is lost all right maria
rachel
i don't know
i feel like
like pop out of nowhere having come off
a flight from like you guys i'm going to
look like
yeah that's true that's true i agree
maria epic if rachel was like i'm
actually not dead yeah that's how she
would say
i actually lie i have one more question
amandla guess what i'm going to ask
about
just guess
i'm hoping that i have a way to ask
about it that you can actually answer so
give her my absolute favorite thing
about star wars is that with every
single movie and show the franchise
evolves and we get new layers to it for
you as a performer what is the most
important thing that you are very eager
to add to that franchise to help it grow
and get stronger i would say i am
excited
to contribute adding to
the the lexicon and the lore um
very complex female characters
i like that i am very excited to see
thank you but i love your question
yeah it's it's not going to be an easy
road but it will be a worthwhile one to
navigate i promise you that's an hour
too so
i know you're up from here i feel like
that news breaking at comic-con of all
places is quite the challenge huge huge
huge congratulations on bodies bodies
bodies everybody out there prioritize
this movie trust me see this
congratulations
you